read the Koran if you're listening to
this check the references learn the
context so learn the verses and read
beyond the verses learn the context fact
check me please and prove me where I'm
wrong I welcome it that's my challenge
to you assalamualaikum greetings of
peace welcome to the Deen show which is
a way of life we try to put out there
for everyone to see helping you
understand Islam and Muslims how you
doing Muhammad hijab my brother how you
been how you doing in the left that's on
the Deen show yeah
now there's a guy out there they calm
louder than Crowder Steven router is it
something like that yeah brought to our
attention and have you noticed there's a
lot of people out there talking about
Islam we were with the friend yesterday
and you had mentioned something
brilliant you said that many people
remember what you were talking about how
people just you know just to stay like
relevant they have to like some
dimension Islam yeah why is this it's
part of like what you were talking about
boys like them is isn't as llama phobia
machine at the woman isn't it so um I
think nowadays Islam is is undoubtably
part of the political narrative whether
it be the Western political narrative
the Middle East and political narrative
the Asian political narrative and it's
something that you know must be talked
about and a lot of people that come
across as public intellectuals want to
make sure that they they have their
opinions on Islam unfortunately the
reality is a lot people that do talk
about Islam a lot people have any
knowledge of it and make incredible
blunders yeah so the guy who was telling
me about him Chris he says you know this
guy you got to look into Steve Crowder
mm-hmm he has some good talking points
on some other topics that he mentions
yeah so the guy Chris tells me he says
that you met he says what but you got to
correct him on Islam yeah he said you
got a disguise totally again another
person out of their Lane absolutely you
follow me so why don't we I thought it'd
be a good idea let's see what he's
talking about
and let's talk to
this stephen louder than crowding why
don't sounds good alright the meccans
were also acting in defense of the
religion since it was Muhammad's goal he
was planning on destroying their idols
establishing Islam by force hence this
part of the verse is so critical because
in the verse 839 where it says religion
is only for Allah meaning that the true
justification of violence was unbelief
of the opposition the justification for
violence against them was simply
unbelief Muhammad further explains in in
the serie um Allah must have no rivals
so again we're coming back to there is
no innocent non-muslim particularly if
you resist Islam not just being
non-muslim but if you say you know what
no I'm not I'm gonna be able to
something to Krishna maybe that is evil
you cannot be innocent so we need to
drill this into you so you understand it
more and more context next clip and he
never responded to evil with evil but
rather he pardoned in for gay what's
this guy talking about well this is a
problem I mean this is a classical
example of cherry-picking a verse from a
surah called surah anfal a chapter of
the Quran chapter of the Quran to
further I put a political agenda so
let's deal with the verse particularly
directly write the verses vacati lu whom
had tell a tycoon if it's not soon we're
gonna dina kalila that and fight them
until there is no fitna fitna means
corruption yeah and the exegetes say
this means shirk which means polytheism
and that all of the religion is made for
Allah first of all most you didn't even
hate for God yeah maybe the creator for
for the Creator that's right because
many people they think right away when
you tell me a lot this is some like
different God yeah no that's it that's a
good point some people think it's a moon
god awesome yeah isn't it so this is the
guy cuz he's a Christian right so this
is the god of Jesus the one Jesus pray
to that's right right we believe in the
same God we don't believe in a triangle
god we don't believe Jesus is God or the
Holy Spirit is God but we believe in the
creator of the universe his name is
Allah Allah just means their God or
literally the one worthy of worship is
this the God and you can go back to this
point yeah Lord's Prayer o our Father if
you change up to rub yeah who art in
heaven hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come
is this the God the same God that's
we don't call him father like you
mentioned but it's the same god of Jesus
basically why don't have some creatures
is why don't you just call him father
well we don't call him father because of
the connotations that the word father
had uh-huh in chapter hundred twelve the
Quran says let me a little amulet that
he has he doesn't beget nor is He
begotten so God we don't believe that he
is a child of anyone nor does he have
any children we think that this is a
later historical development of the
Nicean council and that which came after
in terms of ecumenical councils and then
when we say Allah this is I mean you
have opened up the Arabic Bible yeah and
in Genesis 17 times I think Allah is
used allows used everywhere in the bible
in the arabic bible jeweler christians
jews and christians use the word Allah
yeah to refer to good ok so this is the
God the Creator yeah okay please going
so going back to what we will talk about
social and fell chapter 8 of the Quran
first and foremost is important to know
the historical context so this surah
came down talking about a particular
battle which was the first ever battle
of the Muslims called the Battle of
better the Battle of bedder was actually
a defensive war of the Prophet Mohammed
Salim whereby the people of Mecca and he
talked about the Exile had just exiled
the Muslims they have been kicked out of
their homes and then they had to sell
base in another place which would then
become the capital of the Muslim world
for a while which was Medina Medina was
another city and what happened was they
were coming offensively to attack the
Muslims and the Muslims would respond so
how do we actually substantiate that
with the verses in that particular surah
because someone's ok well you're being
an apologist now you're trying to say
something which is not historically
correct well look at the verses itself I
mean you don't just check chapter 8
verse 39 without checking chapter 8
verse 1
up until whatever is 70 whatever verses
that are in the verb in the chapter so
it's very clear and that the context
starts maybe around verse 8 or 9 where
it's talking about what is the either
come what idea I do come I had a party
fight a knee in the helical that Allah
talks about a particular caravan or two
kept to particular caravans and he sets
the context from there that's where the
verse starts actually before that allah
subhanaw taala says god almighty when we
sell out it means God Almighty
he says that he caused you to come out
of your home so in other words he was in
a position of safety and the Muslims
were position of safety and then he was
caused to come out of their home well in
fre common element we need a lock area
and that there were a portion of Muslims
that didn't want to do this didn't even
want to fight because they felt like
they were being attacked in chapter 30
of that particular surah I lost heart
Allah says because now we're kind of
building up the context right Lost
Planet Allah says where I am cubicle
Idina cafe au lait reduce our co2 Luka
Luka you are we ought to look how are
you joke that when the disbelievers
planned against you O Muhammad that they
will grab you sees you or kill you or
take you out of your homes way I'm
Karuna way I'm Corolla Allah who
idolmaker in that they planned on Allah
planned and Allah is the best of
planners in other words this again
indicates the fact that the Muslims were
defensive because actually who was who
are the ones making the plans to kill
who the Quran is explicit in saying that
the the disbelievers or the polytheists
of the time were the ones who are making
the plans to attack the Muslims then we
lead up to verse 39 because once again
it's not a verse in vacuum it's a verse
in context right so we're trying to lead
up to that verse 39 then tells us that
in this context of war what Carter who
were party Lou whom hatela Toccoa fits
in at somewhere quinidine oh cool Allah
then fight those individuals ie those
people who are fighting you and how can
we also prove that this is a war context
in verse 57 of the same surah allah
mentions the word harp in arabic which
means war so the world war is explicitly
mentioned and you'll find in verse 61
was even more interesting it says we're
either were in Jannah hole illa Selmy
vagina laa
so if they inclined to peace then you
should also inclined to peace so when
you look at the whole surah when you
look at the whole chapter and when you
look at all of these these points you
realize very quickly that this was a
defensive war now we're not saying that
Islam only prescribes defensive Wars
we're just saying that if you put that
in the context this particular verse in
the context of what we talked about this
as a defensive war right that's point
one point two is what he said was
absolutely one of the biggest blunders
I've ever heard a comment a to make of
his you know significance he's got a lot
of viewers can't believe that he was
able to get away with this he says the
reason why Muslims are killing
non-muslims is because of their
non-belief so if someone was a Buddhist
or something like that then they would
be able to be killed this is absolutely
false and can be refuted with two or
three verses of the Quran quite easily
one of them is chapter 22 verse 39 where
it says ordinal in ladino he says that
basically the it has been allowed
permission has been given or zina or C
that means the permission has been given
to the believers to fight be an anomaly
more because they have been oppressed so
this is very significant why is it very
significant because the reasoning
because he says the reason right the
Quran says also the reason the reasoning
behind fighting is given in this verse
so in other words he's saying the reason
that Muslims are commanded were
commanded historically to fight
non-muslims was because there were no
Muslims the Quran says otherwise the
Quran says the reason it says be an
anomaly more because they have been
oppressed now this is extremely
important because here the language that
is used is there is couched and the
Quran is couching this in language of
justification the syntax is a syntax
which is couched or the phraseology used
is phraseology which is couched in
language of justification it's not
language of kill them because they are
non-muslims or disbelievers now that's a
very important point to add to that you
have chapter 60 verse 8 which we've
mentioned in the previous show which was
important to actually mention one more
time on this it says lay and how come on
line and latina let me how to look on
free Deenie
well I'm Yura do come in the arrow
comment about moto Guzzi to a layman
allah hemlocks teen that certainly Allah
does not disallow you from being just or
being kind to the disbelievers they
don't take you out of your home and they
don't kill you that you be just to them
and kind to them that Allah certainly
loves those who are just so in other
words the two things which would enable
someone
to fight someone else who is a
non-believer say or even a believer in
some cases in the Quran chapter 49 it
says you can Muslims can fight each
other in certain cases where there
there's transgression going on is if
their fighting is if there is fighting
so in other words if they're combatants
or if or if they are trying to
physically take you out of your homes so
all of this and obviously chapter 5
verse 32 in the moment enough Sun be
ready enough self-assertive difficut and
I'm a cotton sog MA
so whoever kills a person for other than
murder or creating corruption in the
land as if they called all of humanity
this is a verse which is not abrogated
is still in place and includes Muslims
and non-muslims according to the
consensus of the scholars all of these
are verses which indicate that what this
person is saying is not actually
something you'll find if you look at the
whole Islamic corpus and we've just
looked at the Quran a a a a holistic if
we look at in a holistic way obviously
I've mentioned this in another in our
previous video also we could mention the
fact that the Prophet Muhammad SAW I
solemnly said when cattle mor Hayden
Lamia Hera AAHA tell Jenna that whoever
kills a noncombatant non-believer
he will not smell the fragrance of
heaven ma hit according to modulus
Kalani who is the biggest scholar of
interpretation of the hadith probably
ever to write a commentary of the hadith
in Sunni Muslim history called fat
robbery he says this means someone who
basically is either more equal almost
Atman or he this includes I must at
minimum are head and someone who's
within me so in other words anyone who
there is a contract of who is not a
hobby a hobby is a combatant so you
could actually translate this hadith the
saying of the Prophet whoever kills a
noncombatant he will never smell the
fragrance of heaven a noncombatant
non-believer will never smell the
fragrance of heaven so here the question
is how can you explain those verses and
and and hadith if you if you're saying
that the reason why Muslims are
instructed to kill non-believers
because they there are non-believers how
can you explain 22:39 words as the
reason is because they have been
oppressed how can you explain chapter 60
verse 8 how can you explain chapter 5
verse 32 how can you explain the hadith
which says whoever whoever kills a
noncombatant and non-believer
they will never smell the fragrance of
heaven you can't explain them that's the
reality of it so it becomes a checkmate
position for those individuals who are
advocating the correct position of Islam
which is that we are not allowed to kill
non-combatants non believers we're not
allowed to kill anybody in fact this is
Haram Isis - this is actually a
impermissible to kill anyone except in
the context of war where there's a
leader a Muslim leader who's who is
leading a Muslim army etc but when
you're watching a was it mr. louder you
see him you know he's in front of the
computer and it's like he's given an
exegesis of you know the Quran like he
comes off like this guys knows what he's
talking about he's you know talking fast
he's talking you know with some
confidence absolutely and it really like
pulls people in like he's he's a scholar
he's got eyes you know here's the place
to go yeah what do you have for the
layman I mean now they're watching the
Dean show obviously they're getting you
know if someone's genuine sincere they
wanted what true they're gonna think
like okay I'm not gonna go to a karate
guy to learn jujitsu right I'm not gonna
go to you know the someone who's bashing
Islam to go learn Islam so you come to
the Muslims he's come to us right but
you got a lot of people like this out
there what do you think there are
genders I really really think is
somebody making I I can't substantiate
this with evidence but I genuinely
believe there's some kind of monetary
thing attached to it some kind of
economic incentive attached you know but
putting that to the side what I would
give us an advice to people who are
watching the show who are who actually
listen to us is that an ultra [ __ ]
badarian this word in English language
means someone who is a non specialist
talking about there is something with
something which is not even a non
specialist non aware really someone
who's known aware in not aware of
certainly and he's talking about it this
person is the ultimate ultra creepateria
in that sense because he's gotten the
following that he's got and he thinks
that any opinion that he has has to be
listened to right and people will listen
to it unfortunately I will say to them
that you have to
sources you have to slide you're kidding
yourself you thought you have to dig
deeper basically and they're not you
know are you ready because as we know he
actually invited but it's what I like I
think he invited a Muslim on his show I
don't know we I think that brother that
he was talking to yeah from the talk
Islam yeah I don't know what happened
there but would you be willing to
absolutely waiting to I mean if he if he
knows place he reversed that you know
and he gave that invitation to you to us
he said let's go come on come down with
a job and you want to bring your buddy
Eddie yeah or he can come on our show
you know you're willing right absolutely
I mean that's what we're doing a weekly
basis in the UK anyways I'm all my
videos are debates and discussions with
people of different denominations and
sects and religions yeah well how do you
feel I mean I I don't like to do this
what I'm gonna mention next I don't do
that because I mean these are our Deen
teaches us our this way of life that we
live teaches us to respect people of
other religions he tries to have people
think then and tis this is the opposite
right you know but so I just bring this
up for people like that because he is a
Christian or in and when you're throwing
you're throwing like stones out of glass
housing Christian yeah yeah
so now don't you have things you know
many not things but I mean you get
verses upon verses yeah right in the in
the Bible if two men are fighting and
the wife of one of them comes to rescue
her husband from his assailant you shall
cut off her hand look here is my virgin
daughter I'll bring them out to you now
and you can use them and do to them
whatever you wish but as for this man do
no such outrageous thing a woman should
learn in quietness and full submission I
do not permit a woman to teach or to
assume authority over a man she must be
quiet if someone has a stubborn and
rebellious son who does not obey his
father and mother then all the men have
his town are to stone him to death do
you have a little surprise for you
all these heartwarming passages that I
read to you today
in the Bible actually the Bible in the
in the Bible that you can go ahead and
and share with him that you would say
why don't you give me a before and after
the context yeah of these verses that
talk about for instance well I mean
let's take a look at Deuteronomy chapter
31 verse 18 where it talks about taking
as captives females which are pre
prepubescent and where am I getting this
from I'm getting this from the classical
exegetes of of the Bible the Old
Testament there are binnacle exegesis
people who have written it about it just
look at any exegesis that talks about
what does it what does it mean look at
Deuteronomy chapter 21 verse number 10
onwards which once again talks about
captives and taking these women I said
look at we were talking about Psalms
chapter 127 of the Bible which one again
once again talks about happy is the one
who sees his babies and smashes them on
the rock and some people like some
church fathers says allegorical like
Oregon I think he said this but you
would say I mean we had this discussion
before we were saying that if something
is in the Bible what is the reason for
it to be in the Bible I mean didn't Paul
say something about this you say you
yeah you have in Timothy 3:16 rightly
that all Scripture is for correction for
teaching hmm and correction so that's
something that everything is the word of
God and there's got to be a lesson there
absolutely so the question is what's the
lesson there listen to take a baby's
head and smash or what did the donkey do
you know when you go into a town right
now kill everyone except a virgin girls
yeah this is I don't know yeah I think
is verse chapter 15 where it says go
into the Amalekites and you know take
the babies in a kid everyone even the
donkeys and the cattle and the sheep and
everything but I'm asking what did a
donkey do you know see I don't I don't
really like I don't like to do this I
don't like to offend you know any
Christian do anybody out there this is
specific for someone who's an
antagonistic and I'd like to leave room
for him also you know maybe he's very
just very ill informed but we're here to
help
yeah I mean that's that's the point
really because someone Christi will
actually answer this because a lot of
these things were in the Old Testament
there are some things in New Testament
what Jesus says you know bring my to me
in front of me and I'll slay him and all
these things but looking at these altars
among them injunctions and prescriptions
really yeah that's interesting you bring
that just for a second because people I
mean Jesus we love Him is one of the
mightiest messengers that the crowd ever
sent you know even just to say some
something you know derogatory of Jesus
many people don't know Christians don't
know you can actually by not believing
in Jesus as a Muslim is this you can buy
yourself a one-way ticket to Hellfire
say I deny Jesus is that right that's
absolutely that's absolutely right so
yeah it's really important that you make
that point because people think that
first and foremost as you say without
belief in Jesus you cannot be a Muslim
period really thing is the Messiah that
he was born in the Virgin Mary that he
done all the things like raise the dead
and cured the blind and the leper with
God's permission yeah so no doubt we
have a very they're awesome Christians
you know the Quran actually says that
the Christians will be the closest to
the Muslims yeah
what well let's had you done a club
order then let in a column in the
nasarah the ones that are the closest to
Muslims are the ones who said we are
Christian let's help our friend out
because there is actually another clip
and then that goes into Jesus right okay
Alexa who is the Lord Jesus Christ I
mean we can help see this is a
commonality we have right here I mean
Jesus now he said the Lord Jesus I mean
many people in the Bible our car Lord
you know even today you're from London
right yeah don't they call people we
have the House of Lords the House of
Lords so this is like a term of what
endearment respect yeah in the common
English vernacular absolutely master
yeah in the Bible the what God is used
the word God is used for the for the
devil was useful for different prophets
and stuff like that so I would our they
said what did that elixir say that Jesus
is a fictional fictional character okay
so this is something with mr. louder we
can come together with you know come to
elixir and the Quran says let us come to
a common term between us and you yes
right yeah we what we worship only Allah
only God only the Creator right and
that's what Jesus said also yeah did he
say that he said that he said in John
chapter 5 verse 30 that I did not come
to submit my will to myself but the one
to the one who sent me he also said this
is life eternal that they may know you
the only true God and Jesus who you have
sent that's right
right that's right so how could someone
who was sent be God so now we can go
ahead I mean work together with him to
get likk so at least that you know that
Jesus he wasn't fictional he was
actually you know a messenger who was
sent by the Creator calling people to
worship God hmm
yeah I mean the thing is this I mean
even if we look at this historically
yeah lots of actually written about and
it's it's almost historical consensus
now with scholars from all denominations
even Christians atheists agnostics issed
and so when the one Alexis is saying
that Jesus was a fictional character
this is actually a historical yeah
because majority of historians would say
the other not in fact barmen wrote a
book who was you did Jesus exist or who
was Jesus or something to that effect
and he said he mentions I it's almost
it's almost consensus it's well known
you know that Jesus is did exist as a
matter of historical fact the only
dissenters of the historical view were
were some people who had this theory
called Jesus myth theory or something to
that effect and there was one person
with particulars name's Alex Kasdan or
something like that who believed that at
first he was one of the one of the
historian proponents of this descent
movement of believing in Jesus as being
a stoical figure and he actually changed
his mind thereafter yeah so there were
only a handful really that I know of of
Western historians who did not believe
that Jesus existed man he was some kind
of myth myth but they acted some of them
like Alex Cassadine his surname is he
actually changed his mind on that yeah
so generally speaking we believe that
Jesus existed Christians believe that
Jesus said and historians from all
denominations believed that this was a
historical character so we got that in
common
who got that it doesn't it sound better
I mean for everyone out there I did we
work together on a common ground Yeah
right
instead of hurling insults and whatnot
and I think look not that I think I know
that the Bible actually and we don't
contradict even what the Bible says that
he was a man approved by God he was a
prophet from Nazareth this is right but
the thing is the contention here that we
have is that there's no way is there and
I don't think even even if we did
disagree on this right because we say
look there's no unequivocal verse where
Jesus ever said that I am God worship me
yes right is there there isn't if you
look I read that Bible you won't find
clear
clear clear they have this these things
you know I am and these things ended and
the seams and you say to those well
there's there's a whole discussion we
have we've had debates and once again
this is all much I know if I push the
channel it's my chance with Muhammad
hijab yeah um and I've had actually I've
had a formal debate with one Christian
called dr. Richard Boggs and we had we
went that flew at a discussion about
basically how why why is the twenty did
you guys assault each other no no did
you hit him no how did it end it was a
good it was a good really good debate it
was excellent
I mean that's something to learn from
now but away at the bait him twice which
shows that you know there's yeah
continuity in our relationship so he
didn't insult you you didn't sold him
absolutely but some crucial issues you
would get trying to get to the bottom um
yeah I mean I mean that's civil man
that's what it is it's being human right
okay so now we are Jesus being known as
a man a messenger prophet and the Quran
confirms that why do you think some
people now you know they they go above
and beyond like the Christian that you
had a nice debate with and now they take
offense to that well I mean the thing is
I mean obviously Christian the Christian
belief is that Jesus is God
yeah and that he is the son of God and
he's part of the the Trinity the triune
entity of God or that God is one God in
three different present the Bible have I
mean sons by the tons absolutely all
over the place yeah yeah for sure yeah
it says Matthews blessed be the
peacemakers for they shall be called the
sons of God Adam is a son David is a son
every I mean every you know everyone is
a son son son so if we're saying look
this one is saying he's a son the other
one saying uh some and we're just saying
look hey you know we're confusing right
so in the in Nicaea decreed the Nicene
Creed which is formulated a thing
sometime main
325 yeah it said it puts a qualification
on that so it says that Jesus is
begotten not made yeah so there and he's
from the substance of God it took Goethe
Frazer
he's from the substance of God so they
used these terminologies to try and
distinguish him being a son from other
sons but really and truly what this
constitutes I mean a lot of historians
would argue that this is just absorption
of the Greek mythological culture that
existed within the Roman Empire at the
time so because if you look at the
historical development of
the Medical Council's from you know
Nicaea 325 and the Antioch 341 or
Constantinople 381 or Kassadin 451 all
of these you'll see a development of the
Trinity and that development is well
documented by historians we know that
basically there was a depreciation in in
arianism Arianism most about
subordination is amis idea of Jesus
being subordinate to God and that the
idea of a Trinity was there there
thereafter enforced by force through
Theodosius ii who was in charge and the
roman in a particular part the roman
empire and in their 380s in that period
of time so the trinity is a historical
construct which was developed out of out
of these things but generally what we as
muslims believe as you say is that Jesus
was not God he was a prophet as it says
in acts 2 chapter 2 verse 222 whatever
may be there was a man approved by God
with monitors and miracles and science
and so for that perspective we say that
we don't have him and we don't deified
Jesus Christ because he himself never
claimed to be a god did Jesus ever peace
be upon him ever say look now if you
don't believe in me I don't have to be
exact words but you know paraphrasing
something in the lines of look if you
don't believe in me as a god or a
literal son of God that I came to die
for your sins that you're going to the
Hellfire boy it doesn't say that because
because that's something that you know
that's not salvation absolutely did he
ever say that so okay you've had I mean
I'm sure because you've had many debates
and many talks and I have myself you
know with Bible scholars I've had I mean
Bible scholars you know graduates from
prestigious universities like Joe dr.
Gerald Dirk's and so I've sat with many
people at the end when they went into
you know the text they went into in the
seminary where they going to textual
criticism but they saw that a lot of
many of these things they're not there
they've been changed altered so that's
not what's making this stuff oh no doubt
yeah so what what do you what do you at
the end when you talk to someone like
louder from Crowder
you know what advice do you give him
like you know we want to leave a door
open where tomorrow like we
sit we can talk have some coffee and it
doesn't have to be you know all of this
I know ma city yeah well I I think
that's a really good way of putting it
we don't want to we want to open doors
or pathways of communication yeah
to be frank and to put this in in a very
blunt way if we did believe in what he
thinks we believe in then the question
is why we're not doing it why do you not
find of the 1.7 billion Muslims are we
all just cowards well you know what what
what is the reason why we're all thus
restrained is it because we're faithful
of the law no it's the reason why we
don't do that stuff is simply because we
don't believe in that stuff and what we
do believe in is it's discussion as it
says in the Quran o Allah submitter
public a big mess with model has no
agenda nobility here S on chapter 6
verse 125 where it says you know speak
with them ie the people that you
disagree with disbelievers debate with
them
Bunnicula with wisdom and beautiful
preaching etc so here well and well and
argue with them in the ways which are
best which I did own bility hey hacen we
believe from the Socratic precepts we
believe in the idea of discussion and
even debate sometimes discussion debate
so with with Christ Crowder Steven Giada
louder Crowder yeah steven crowder what
would say to him is that since our
religion instructs us not to kill
innocent people but also to discuss with
people of a different religious
background these issues these important
issues will say let's do it mm-hmm
you've got nothing to fear you've never
really had has he ever had I'm not sure
if he's ever had a conversation with a
Muslim a discussion where he's actually
sincere and receptive and open to
criticism and open to correction yeah if
he's if he does fulfill that criteria
because we're always an intelligent guy
I mean I've heard it's a really
intelligent guy and these things I mean
Steve was telling us yesterday so if
he's that kind of person then why not
have a discussion with us and we could
potentially edify him on certain issues
yeah we had our Arthur Wagner who was a
far-right conservative from Germany and
their whole slogan was Islam doesn't
belong in Germany he accepted Islam
unbelievable and he at the end now what
he wants to do is show the Conservatives
there that there are
of similarities Wow between Islam and
the Conservatives yeah I mean that's a
really good point and not only that
there's a lot of there's a lot of
overlap between Islamic injunctions and
Orthodox Jewish injunctions what we how
we dress a lot of that stuff is very
similar so a lot of these commentators
when they criticize Islam I I just don't
understand criticism if this is a true
criticism if you believe in it a lot of
their criticisms can be applied to the
Orthodox Jewish communities or even even
valid invalid local Christian
communities in the Bible Belt in this
country so the question is why are you
specifying this criticism to Muslims in
Islam because it seems to me is
politically driven or even economically
driven yeah and we'd be more more
powerful together working together on
some of these common moral social issues
social issues and that's good you
mention that point because there is that
that talk you had with the Jewish
gentleman yeah and you bring that up
right that in London and they usually
attack people such as our friend here
they attack Muslims on these issues or
but you actually brought this out you
were driving right and you were in
London yeah and then you had like men on
one side women on one side you had they
had their own ambulance they had their
own section their own like cosmetics
they had their their own like police
police literally a police because the
city has law right so they have their
own lock and I say see the police they
don't police so you're not technically
police yeah yeah but they got their own
security force yeah on the street right
and these are not these are Orthodox
Jews yeah right we don't hear the news
by the way for Muslim perspective good I
think he also mentioned somewhere
because we were looking at this before
the show somewhere he mentions 929 mhm
up to 9 verse 29 of them yeah if you
look at the silver to be which is one of
the most extensive surface 0xe Jesus's
of the Quran Karim of the noble quran it
mentions about this first and foremost
it's talking about
he says it's another five verse talking
about fighting jews and christians of a
certain peak of a certain kind the
romans who in fact were a threat to the
muslim community and obviously once
again this is this is in context and we
need to talk about that and maybe
another video another time but i've
spoken about it in
another videos I've done but if you look
at the silikal to be who bought image is
really interesting he says that Jews and
if in an Islamic governance if you had
an assignment governance Jews and
Christians would not only be allowed to
live within the Muslim world obviously
that's that's a given
they'd have to be protected by Muslims
there and the protection is absolute so
in other words whenever there is any
kind of problem with those communities
Muslims had to actually intervene and
protect number two that they would that
the because a lot people call it easier
because though the verse mentions this
word easier the jizya he mentions is
like half a dinar for for the entire
year so in other words the amount he
says of tax that these reducing
Christians have to pay with in many
cases if you do the calculation be less
than the amount Muslims would have to
pay so most so Jews and Christians would
live under protected if this was an
Islamic governance according to Al
Cordoba which is a classic one dilution
scholar they would live with the Muslims
coexist with the Muslims they would pay
less taxes than Muslims there in that
context they would have to be defended
if there was if there was ever a stake
moreover he also says something really
interesting if he says a lakh or two he
says if they wanted to drink alcohol if
they wanted to eat pork they could do
that in their communities in other words
they would have their own freedoms if
they wanted to have their own courts to
solve their own domestic matters and on
their own religious matters their own
religious quotes that could be
facilitated and that was facilitated a
Tom Vargo hOAT pub and others and by the
way this is a template it's the Islamic
template that a lot of Westerners are
not aware of they think and that under
Islam as this person thinks if Aslam had
control of there was an actual Islamic
rule that that would necessitate putting
Jews and Christians under this kind of
oppressing them or attacking them or all
these things and obviously that's not
substantiated by number one the
evidences in the Quran and Sunnah number
two the commentaries of the Quran so no
from the classical scholars and it's
interesting that of course to be says
that because in his region of the world
is a region in Spain where convivencia
with me it was with took place which is
the idea of coexist convent in Spanish
means coexistence between Jews
Christians and Muslims
as we know really interesting and this
is as a point of historic extrapolation
we could say when the Alhambra
declaration was happening and the
Inquisition was going on the Christians
actually left so the Jews actually left
the Christians and and migrated towards
the Muslim world because they felt like
the Christians were going to execute
them kill them and then they left and
went to the Muslim world to seek
protection this also happened to the
Ottomans and many times in history this
has happened but it seems like the
social and historical commentary of
political commentators like this is so
shallow and surface based that they
don't bring these things out I was in
Florida not too long ago with Sheikh
Bilal mmm and nabla Phillips another
share yeah
and he's from Yemen a very nice brother
and he was telling me how he was talking
to some of the Christians and in the
Arabic Bible because this is another
like spook word people use Sharia right
to scare you to spook you and he
mentioned that in the arabic sharia is
mentioned over 200 sometimes in the
Bible yeah so he mentions this offshore
clip of him speaking we find that in the
in the Bible and the Old Testament and
also in the New Testament the term
Sharia is used and in the Arabic Bible
for example in the New Testament the the
term Sharia is mentioned more than 250
times in your Bible in the Bible right
because not everybody who reads the
Bible is American right there's some
Christians who read the Bible and what
language do they speak if they're Arabic
they're reading the Bible in Arabic and
Arabic I know right alright Bible is way
older than the English Bible and what is
in Sharia in the Arabic Bible yeah if
you go to any Arabic Christian and you
ask them about the term Sharia does the
term shady I exist in the in the Bible I
think if they are honest they will say
yes so as the Sheikh Sheikh is showing
like you know many of these you know
words that are used for instance you
know the 10 commandments can we say that
Sharia yeah a lot of the second wife not
all of them I mean are in compliance
with the Sharia I would believe Allah
well given to Moses we believe the
actual the stones and the part they will
get they were given to Moses so
we do believe in most of these like for
example with the scheme' chapter six
verse four of the Bible Shamus O'Reilly
Adonai Eloheinu I've had the hero Israel
your Lord and is our Lord as one God
this is something which is almost
synonymous with you know believe in one
God the towhead message of Islam yeah so
this is something that people create
like it's a it's a often use the word
boogeyman like you know Sharia they
often think of you know the hands
getting cut off right someone's getting
stoned which all of these things when
you talk about this paint Penal Code
what does it make up like 1% it's a very
minor it's a very minor part of the of
the Islamic corpus yeah conveniently you
know forget about you know taking care
of your parents charity trying to
eradicate poverty you know prayer all of
these things that you know reification
of the heart and the soul pure
monotheism well you see that they
conveniently forget about these and all
the things that they don't like about
Islam they're implementing in this
country I mean the death penalty still I
mean as far as I know you can crime from
wrong but it's still in it is in the
operation many of the stations of
America right yeah so it's not as if the
death penalty is something because was
one of the things that the Chris has
Islam on that death penalty but it's
something that and by the way the
Islamic model for the death penalty is
much less strict than the American model
yeah because it allows for forgiveness
at every level
yeah it allows for example if a mother
her son died so this son died
perpetrator she can actually forgive the
perpetrator in some cases that the party
or the judge will say well that person
is a serial killer and they might decide
to overrule it and forgiveness is not
always best but in most cases Islam
actually advocates forgiveness in these
cases
so is it I would say that the the model
of Islamic death penalty if you will and
obviously this only applies in the
context of an Islamic governance is much
more strict than the American model this
this is a this is amazing because you
have so many so many things that are
there in Islam and when it's put in the
proper context it's a mercy for Humanity
absolutely it's pure justice you
in Harvard you have in the Harvard
prestigious Harvard University why would
they put this verse up that talks it has
an ayah from Quran you know about this
yeah you know talking about the justice
even if you'll be against yourselves
right right this is in Harvard the
prestigious Harvard University are these
dummies just putting this up you know so
when people really look into Islam
sincerely then you know they're not
cherry-picking like we started the show
with yeah you know they get to benefit
from from these things you know
absolutely and hopefully our friend here
can can benefit from some of the things
that we're talking about let's go back
to and then we'll come back to
addressing some also some areas of
concern for some people well let me just
get into that someone says you know oh
so you're the same guy that follows a
book that says go ahead and beat down
your wife right right right
what do you say well this there's a
verse in chapter four verse a for
because these are some there's a comment
there's like three four five you know
things I did just don't you know
apostasy ya know beat white beating what
what else is another one that you get
hit with when you're you know talking to
someone well this is one of them so the
kind of I would say one of the big ones
today is really like gender related yeah
men and women and the difference between
men and women and all these kind of
things and in some cases and then before
you answer it's like many people they're
not even looking you know for the truth
they just want to throw this in your
face right just to put you under the bus
exactly yeah exactly and once again is
this funny sometimes to see who's asking
the question because sometimes it could
be an Orthodox Jew or say a Christian
who in their very book it says it's very
similar things to the things that they
don't like or the things that they're
trying to criticize well met in many
cases actually more severe more yeah
it's more severe what reminds me of uh
you know the woman she's trying to help
her husband she tried to help her
husband from the thief yeah and now
because she accidentally like in the you
know the midst of things she ended up
you know touching him in a certain place
you're supposed to cut off her hand know
what's the context there you know that
Oh in the Bible in the by holding his
genitals and all those kind of things
and yeah if a woman holds a man's
genitals and you have to cut our hand
off and all these kind of things yeah
that's another verse in the Bible a more
clear one is the one in Timothy
I think it's first time we see Timothy
where it talks about a woman cannot talk
in church and if she talks inch and that
the head of the house is her husband as
a very traditional stuff I mean it's in
their Bible right yeah if you I mean if
you you attend the church without a
hijab right cut off her hair yeah it's
clear you bought a shave the hair off
yeah also excuse still do that yeah
author of Jewish women so a lot of them
shave their hair off but we're gone
there are clear things in the Bible and
that surprises me when sometimes again I
would never say this in a way to
belittle a but when somebody throws
these stones out of a glass of hose
right we say that this doesn't show that
the religion is false
yeah by the way I mean it's not an
argument against the religion because
all we're doing is form philosophical
perspective we're using our socially
constructed 21st century Western norms
and we're pitting them against the
biblical the Quranic or whatever
narrative and what that is is actually
constitutes a fallacy called the fallacy
of present ISM the fallacy of present
ism is using present ideas of the 21st
century narrative to try and actually
disprove other things which are moral
based well that's actually a macron
istic in other words you're using a
present idea to superimpose it on a
let's say a previous society or whatever
is well that doesn't show that your idea
is true in their idea is false it just
shows that you you have a value judgment
a subjective aesthetic value judgment
which happens to differ from that which
existed pre a beforehand but in any rate
I mean I mean a lot of these things are
misconceptions like you're mentioning
them I was in the in the Quran about
beating in these things and just to kind
of quickly summarize this verse it's
really interesting because this verse
starts off by saying it's chapter 4
verse type forces well if some new shoes
or knife I saw when I was your wonderful
mulatto are already born so when a tonic
on filet a philosopher who are a hidden
Sevilla allah subhanaw taala says if you
fear their new shoes
ie you for your wives you know choses
rebellion and it can take different
forms
now the first thing I would say to
someone who's asking this question is
this as follows really I mean I would
say to someone let's say for example who
is um I'm not gonna say feminist or
someone whose please women's rights
anyone right say to them did you accept
did you believe that in all cases in all
cases a man a husband can never touch a
woman against her will in all cases
absolute absolutely all cases you might
say yeah I don't believe in any case
it's justified for a woman to touch her
husband against his will
sorryi husband such a wife against her
will in any physical way so exactly fine
what if she is what if she's killing the
child or endangering the child's health
in a dramatic way and by the way this is
not an anomalous example because if you
find the NSPCC which is a British
charity which deals with children's
health and things like that
they actually reported that the majority
of fatalities or deaths of children are
from from women because just not because
the women are worse than men or more
evil than men or as the Bible indicates
in Genesis but it's actually because
women have more interaction time with
with with the words children with their
children generally speaking as mothers
mothers have more erections time with
their children so this is actually a
real case study if we see a mother
because we're looking at the
philosophical or epistemological roots
if you see a mother her husband sees his
wife abusing the child is he allowed to
intervene the physical physically
touching one against her was yeah the
feminist will cause her answer here
probably we weren't objecting to that
say fine so now we have to understand
that we've broken the original thing
that we've said because originally we
said that absolutely no yeah there is no
case in which a woman can a man can
touch woman against her will so but then
the woman will say okay well but that's
it that's an exceptional circumstance we
say all right so you're saying in
certain exceptional circumstances
husbands can touch a woman physically
against her will
that's very interesting say if she's
hitting him she's attacking him in a
violent way which could cause harm
because women despite popular
stereotypical understanding might be
wicked I mean physically but they're not
completely incapable of hurting a man so
say for example grabs a weapon or she
physically trusts
Kim is he last to defend himself and
physically touch her against her will in
that context so let's say a fair-minded
feminist will say yeah okay he can do
you can do as much as it needs as he
needs in order to get her of him so I
would say them that is the case then
we've agreed already then say why is
that why have we agreed so well the
reason why we've agreed is actually
because this verse is not telling a man
how to beat up his wife it's not in fact
the Prophet explicitly told us in a
hadith in Timothy let of the elect of
the reboot in may Allah do not hit the
women's servants of Allah do not hit
them so if anyone says okay well Islam's
normative position is to go and hit the
wives to discipline them or something
this is against the the Quranic and
Islamic or hadith narrative this verse
is not telling a man how to hear or beat
up his wife this is telling how I'm a
man or husband how to defend himself
against his wife because the thing is
the nature of man is that a man is prone
to in a more biological predetermined
way to a kind of aggressive behavior so
this Quranic injunction these three
steps worn same from sexual intercourse
and then you can apply dhaba which we
can explain later on or I've already
explained in a couple of videos of mine
which we don't maybe I want to discover
this this discussion then you can do
this right so so someone with my
argument how comes it's not mention this
word is not mentioned in relation to
women I would say actually is mentioned
in relation to him in the same word in
chapter 4 I think verse 28 128 126 128
it says women are to affect me in Bali
had no shoes on our other fella Gina how
a fella do Nahal ahima is Allah happy no
matter how a soon well it says that if a
woman fares from her husband no shoes Oh
errant are not means being neglected so
there's two things whereas in the verse
and 434 is only month one thing that was
mentioned which was no shoes which was
rebellion here there are two things I
mentioned then she can start a
reconciliation with her husband and she
could start working and she actually has
a right at any point to go to a kadhi
she has a right to our judge if there's
actually any damage done to her she can
it was instantaneously any physical
actual physical damage we're not talking
about you know something which is not
substantive or something which is not
real or whatever it may be or he hurt
her when he was rolling in the bed when
he's sleeping or something like this
no we're talking about some serious
stuff there at any point yeah she could
she could actually start a
reconciliation process you can start a
case against him
the question would be made Nassau why is
it the case that was a man is mentioned
dollar-wise mentioned which is a kind of
physical recourse and it's not mentioned
with a woman the answer is because men
are physically more a more prone to
violence and so there needed to be some
kind of refining oh okay cap put on what
a man's normative or default position
would otherwise be anyways and number
two is because if that same injunction
was useful for a woman it would put her
in a disadvantageous position because
actually Foreman you know initiates
something physical with a man and the
man responds yeah and what he would in
many cases perceive as self-defense then
she'd be put in a disadvantageous
position in which he can harm her
physically so really the Quranic
discourse is not one because the hadith
says of the Prophet in the mindset of
Shikata Quadrajet Allah certainly men
are equal to women by the way the
scholars I say that this means equal it
means that they're twins or whatever but
also means equal in them in the set of
Chicago Quadrajet generally speaking we
believe in a general equality but the
other end situations yeah well we
believe that actually a man has a
certain right over woman and the woman
sometimes has a certain right over a man
like in the custody of children like his
mother's she's three times more
important than the man like in Mahara
which is a dowry like in many cases in
divorce she can preoccupy the house he
lives in for three months it's his house
but she has to stay there there's so
many things we can we can actually list
that a woman has a right over a man in
and the opposite is also true in Islam
so there are some exceptional
circumstances and by the way this is not
even against Western society because
frankly Western civilization has made
exceptions for women and certain things
maternity leave the army there's a drug
there's been so many drafts for men to
go to the army there's no all women
draft in the history
of America really but there's been a
women armies so there's so many things
here we can say but the point is in a
nutshell
a lot of these misconceptions is because
they're approaching the Quran with their
lenses right and if they want to have a
genuine on selling of the Quran they
have to understand the Quran from what
is telling us rather than what would try
and superimpose on it if you collect the
data and you look at how many women here
are being battered abused you follow me
yeah
have you ever looked into that and you
see like skyrocketing statistics now you
do a contrast and see because I think
there's more men terrorizing their homes
by their women by Muslim men surprised
by they can beat up by their by their
whys and the opposite but if you look at
the data I mean I don't know if you look
how many women are battered and beat
here yeah you know and then someone has
the audacity to try to you know throw
this back at Muslims to try to say that
you know Islam when it actually you know
championed the rights of Islam and
absolutely Islam is a religion where the
Prophet of Islam clearly explicitly
unequivocally unambiguously said layer
totally buoy may Allah do not hit the
woman slaves of Allah do not hit women
now what if someone says look because
the next thing is that the problem Hamid
peace be upon him he's the example just
like Jesus at his time he was the
example of Islam at that time right
submission to the will of God Moses at
his time he was the example of Islam at
that time just to clarify to Islam is
nothing new it came now so no it's a
complete form but at that time was there
Aslam during Jesus's time Islam is
submission so he says himself in John
chapter 5 verse 30 I have not come to
submit to my own will but submit to the
will of the one who sent me
isn't that equal Islam that means it's
luck okay good so now the example for
Loudoun and Crowder if you need if you
choose to not accept or anyone else
problem Ahamed peace be upon him because
Jesus was only sent for a particular
time ticular period right and so those
people at his time he wasn't sent as a
messenger for all times correct that's
right and there's a verse in the Bible
that substantiates that doesn't it which
one yes yes yes about that he was sent
for only that don't go in the way of the
Gentiles for I was already sent for the
lost sheep of Israel exactly now problem
how many peace be upon when we look
to him we would say that he never hit as
is stated that he never hit anyone right
that's right I she says that herself
right and now this is interesting that
they will go and rebuttal and say no he
actually did hit a shot I think he does
say that somewhere yeah I think I'm not
sure if we've got the video but yeah
there is a there was a clip of him
saying something like that now what do
you say about that
well this is very embarrassing actually
because I assure herself who is the as
he put down she was the third wife of
the Prophet in terms of chronology of
woman he married she says in a hadith
which is narrated in in in many I had
actually more than one book she says
that the Prophet Mohammed so I said I
mean he never hit a servant he never hit
a woman now what he's referring to the
Haditha what when she left and the
Prophet put on his reader and he put on
these things and and he went after and
he the word in Arabic usely heard that
letter literally means to touch or to to
hold you can say to hold so he/she says
the word in Arabic is not adorable by
the way because da da ba could range
from in the chronic discourse is
mentioned in chapter 73 of the Quran
this is the word that's used in 434 it
could mean and they translate as hit
which is fine they can translate as hey
it's no problem
but it's also it means I mean the word
is used in chapter 73 of the Quran
well haram al driven a fill out the able
to Hoonah men for delay well hurry a
horse in a few similar this verse da da
ba in this particular passage of chapter
73 of the Quran other 73 or 74
it literally means doing theorem so but
it to put your hands on the soil or to
tap something very slowly or even rub it
so da da ba could have a range it could
mean to tap something and it could mean
also to strike someone to fight someone
to climb someone and this is a hadith of
Abu Huraira in adorable I had Akuma
Holly article watch which is also with a
cartel I had a whole field tackle watch
that if anyone who fights with your
brother do not punch his face or if any
of you is mentioned in chapter 47 verse
4 yeah fedora burger Cobb strike at the
next chapter 8 verse 3 so it could have
a range the word dollar wa has arranged
the word in the hadith inside Muslim
the one that there that he mentions yeah
and this is a long hadith and long had
an interesting that he's looking at this
Pacific you know part one small part of
absolute this word is not used in the
hadith mmm-hmm so even that was he can't
say that that means heating in any
context because we said there's a word
is a scope of that word in Arabic
language but the word that he uses does
not mean it does not fit that scope
it literally means it could mean
touching holding grabbing poking it
could mean all those things so frankly
and the testimony of Aisha herself is
that he never hit me he never had any of
his wives he never hit any of the
servants so her testimony disqualifies
than anything else a malicious attempt
to try to deduce yeah you know that yeah
absolutely yeah
tell me now you know what's interesting
is that you have for a genuine sincere
person who comes at looking at the life
for the last and final messenger sent to
mankind problem and peace and busted be
upon there's too many stories there's
telling examples of mercy of justice of
compassion why do you think many people
they end up going to to certain areas
right collapse I got strolls really
clutching at straws
right going and looking how to interpret
this in such a malicious way out of
totally out of context you know there's
a beautiful story of a man named foo
mama even know that he was a enemy of
the state
mmm-hmm and I'll just kind of give you a
condensed version I'm sure you know
about it he was someone who I believe
killed some of the companions of proper
common while we if there's a suspect
without a criminal without a jury
without you know going through the due
process of law we've been known to send
you know drones to kill you know US
citizens and now this man was a true and
an enemy of the state at that time I'm
sorry he can't killed the Companions of
the Prophet he got detained they put him
in the mosque that's what I fed him
that's what took care of him he got to
observe what's going on and then later
he was released right but he ended up
coming back and he said the famous words
that I had I I hated no other face more
than I hated your face talking about
problem now I love no other face like I
love you that's right I mother thought
his story is absolutely unbelievable
because isn't I don't believe it yeah he
was detained as you say in the Masjid of
the Prophet Mohammed Salim he put him he
tied him up the Sahaba were just living
their lives normally what the Prophet
wanted to do was to show an expose this
man is slamming action and oh my cell he
he basically decided at no point they
asked him do you want to become Muslim
he didn't want become Muslim he actually
said I don't want to become Muslim when
he was imprisoned then the Prophet was
at that particular time I couldn't very
well be in the case they would have been
executed because the executions were
very commonplace they had every right to
kill him also yes right right he was an
enemy of the say as you say all these
kind of things he let him go
when omama left he actually as you say
he came back he said to the Prophet they
said well as you say your face was the
most hated face to me now it's the most
beloved face to me but he the the
Companions announced on whether you
become Muslim when you're in a position
of being a prisoner he said I didn't
want you to think but I was gonna become
Muslim because I was being coerced into
it or because I was being pressured into
it he was a man of dignity of men around
this is intelligent man this is like a
chieftain a president equivalent to you
know a prime minister he was the head of
his year and he was allowed to leave and
he was allowed to leave yeah this is
amazing isn't it and I mean we can just
go on even with this story isn't it so
he had controlled the trade routes
coming in this is another example of the
the mercy of the Prophet SAW some and he
had stopped him Josh he stopped this the
the the food coming in to temeka they
were starving the Quraish there's a
story of a person called Sokka yeah
whoo-hoo all so he hated the Prophet all
these things and he came so I should try
and execute the Prophet and as he was
moving forward his camel the the legs of
his camel would actually sink into the
sand and he would think why is this
happening and he ended up embracing
Islam as well so there's many amazing
stories like that and the Prophet told
him that you're going to you're going to
actually happen s the treasures of the
then leader of the near half kisara of
the the leader of the Persian Empire and
he did at the top so the prophecy this
was interesting because now the problem
Hamid peace and blessing be upon because
to mama he was in charge of the the
certain foods coming into Mecca and now
he had boycotted there
and then Abu Sufyan he ended up
contacting the Prophet saying man let
let tell this man instruct him to let
the food back in now if the prophet saw
some peace be upon him he wanted to you
know end things there like they had done
to him right they boycotted them they
starved the Muslims tortured them but
what did he do he removed the the
injunction right so man these are the
things like in this guy he had louder
from Crowder he hasn't killed any of the
Companions I mean we still hope that we
pray that there's hope for people like
him this man now he accepted Islam he's
living Islam he was you know advocate
for Aslam calling people to Islam so we
hope that through just covering covering
a few things we we've opened some hearts
that are out there maybe some of his
viewers what advice now would you give
to a louder from crowd or anybody else
tuning and watching him and he's been
misleading a lot of people with a lot of
this these misconceptions I'll just say
to him that when you talk about Islam
you're talking about religion according
to Pew of 1.7 1.8 billion people which
is according to Pew Research by 2100 the
end of the century will be one like a
third of the world with Muslim well 35%
oh I don't know what they've said so
we're talking about the religion of a
third of humanity I mean I'm not saying
everyone of that number is gonna be a
practicing Muslim or completely you know
embracing all of the Islamic injunctions
except about when you talk about such a
religion they ought to be done with
integrity intelligence and education
just like you do with your other topics
that you talk about I'm sure so why
don't you do that with this because it's
actually a very very important thing
when you talk about religion and if you
come across as ignorant about religion
or ignorant about what according to Pew
what will be a third of the world's
belief by the end of the century so it
puts you in a very bad light it puts you
in a position where people will think
looking outside probably of the USA
context looking at your show that you
don't know you're talking about and so
what we're saying is that it's sometimes
it's good to kind of acknowledge that
we're all we're all ignorant of
something this there's lots of things I
don't know I'm talking about and Eddie
doesn't know we're not especially we
don't understand but it's just knowing
it's just knowing your limitations man's
gotta know his limitations gotta know
your lane and it's wanting to grow
spiritually intellectually
psychologically and we're saying that we
can provide that service for you so long
as you have that open mind open heart
you don't come with if you even if you
are arrogant with us we will deal with
you in a way which is as the Quran says
is fabulous yes and you know responding
the way which is better you know for the
most part so that that is how our
recourse would be I would say that if
you wanna have a discussion with us we
you can you can you can find us the Deen
show we have discussions I have
discussions a weekly basis anyways with
interlocutors which are in my there are
actually people that we don't agree with
totally for different religions
different nominations and ends up being
quite good we get the elephant out of
the room yeah how we can move on and if
there's some extra tension you can get
on the mats huh just have some fun I
heard somewhere we can have fun I mean
just get this stress out you know what I
mean yeah common sense tells you that
look Christians aren't going anywhere
yeah
Muslims aren't going anywhere yeah so
we're not going anywhere we're gonna
have to be neighbors learn to get along
right why are you gonna insult your
neighbor why are you gonna you know
that's childish man yeah so I I thank
you thank you for being with us helping
us cover this topic and God willing we
can have louder from Crowder he can
invite you on and we can continue from
there and we can help change some of
these people's
Mis notions misconceptions and people
can benefit because that's where the
Deen show is about calling people to
worship the Creator not the creation to
live in peace with your neighbors and
those around you get educated get
informed if you have any other questions
you can also call us right now 1 800 662
Islam we also got that number
thank you brother de zaak l'homme can
also pass out